after a rough patch under the
administration of president rodrigo
duterte the philippines and the united
states have reaffirmed an enduring
partnership
on saturday u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken met with the country's
newly elected leader ferdinand marcus jr
and i reiterated our ironclad commitment
to the u.s philippines mutual defense
treaty and reaffirmed
that an armed attack on philippines
armed forces public vessels or aircraft
in the south china sea would invoke us
mutual defense commitments under that
treaty
lincoln arrived from phnom penh where
foreign ministers of the 10-member
association of southeast asian nations
discussed the growing tension in the
taiwan strait china is conducting
military drills until sunday in response
to u.s house speaker nancy pelosi's
visit to the self-ruled island of taiwan
the
total disproportion
between a peaceful visit on the one hand
and
escalatory military maneuvers on the
other i think is very clear and very
clear to
countries throughout the region
president marcos said the latest moves
add to an already tense situation
this just demonstrates how
volatile
the
international
diplomatic seed is
case in point the south china sea where
the philippines and china have had a
territorial dispute
in 2016 the philippines won an
international ruling invalidating
china's vast claims in the region but
china has continued its military buildup
and incursions
the marcos administration has emphasized
its adherence to a one china policy
but with tension high in water so near
the philippines it will be looking to
the united states for a renewed
commitment to a long-standing military
alliance
partner below al jazeera manila